Сьогодні ми знайомимося з підлітками Німеччини. Для початку з'ясуємо,
що для них важливо в житті?
Сім'я, друзі і спорт.
Щастя і здоров'я моїх близьких.
Мої хом'як, собака і телефон.
Щоб у світі було менше несправедливості.
Школа теж важлива.
Треба закінчити з добрими оцінками, щоб здійснювати потім свої мрії.
Отже, згідно з опитуваннями, підліткам у віці від 14 до 17 років
у Німеччині важливі сім'я, друзі, довіра, чесність, відданість і час для відпочинку.
Рівень стресу підвищується в школі.
І це не дивно. Таке відчуття, що у школярів тут постійно контрольні.
Багатьох представників юного покоління цікавлять також екологія і клімат.
До міжнародного руху Fridays for Future на початку 2019 року
приєдналися і німецькі школярі.
Якби я став канцлером, я би виступав за охорону природи, рівні права і проти расизму.
Я би скеровувала більше грошей в освіту,
адже багато шкіл потребують модернізації.
Я би виніс проблеми школи на федеральний рівень
і поліпшив шкільну інфраструктуру.
Я би боровся з антисемітизмом і расизмом.
Незалежно від релігії і національності
всі повинні мати можливість працювати.
Я би зробив ставку на екологію і діалог з іншими країнами.
Час відпочити. Що роблять юні німці у вільний час?
Граю у футбол.
Американський футбол.
Танці.
Гуляю і бігаю.
Займаюся спортом, граю в хокей
і теніс в клубі. Зустрічаюсь з друзями.
Найчастіше зустрічаюся з друзями або граю у футбол.
Музика, як ви бачите!
Граю на гітарі і контрабасі.
Спорт, друзі і комп'ютерні ігри.
Гандбол, піаніно і малювання.
З друзями на вулиці - так зазвичай проводять вільний час
підлітки у віці від 14 до 19 років.
Фортепіано і спів - найпопулярніші музичні заняття.
А що слухає ця вікова група? Хіп-хоп,
поп і німецький хіп-хоп.
У спорті інтереси розходяться за гендерною ознакою.
Хлопчики надають перевагу футболу і баскетболу.
Дівчатка - танцям і верховій їзді.
Але футбол теж не сильно відстає.
І всі ходять на фітнес.
70% грають у відеоігри кілька разів на тиждень.
Найпопулярніші - Minecraft, Fortnite і FIFA.
А чим втамовують голод німецькі підлітки?
Піца.
Без чого це покоління не може жити?
Смартфон. Смартфон є у 95% підлітків.
Найпопулярніші додатки - WhatsApp, Instagram і YouTube.
У Німеччині є свої інфлуенсери з фітнесу,
краси, ігор та екології.
А з кого молоді німці беруть приклад?
Мій великий приклад - це мої батьки.
Ілон Маск, тому що він дуже успішний підприємець.
Один німецький репер.
Мій великий приклад наразі це Мішель Обама,
бо вона надзвичайно розуміна і впевнена.
Тепер про вікові обмеження.
З якого віку в Німеччині можна:
сідати за кермо?
Без супроводу - з 18 років. Із супроводом - з 17 років.
Брати уроки водіння - з 16 з половиною.
У кіно після 22-ої без батьків можна з 16 років.
На федеральних виборах голосують з 18 років.
Але на регіональних виборах в деяких регіонах - з 16.
Палити в громадських місцях можна з 18 років.
Міцні спиртні напої дозволені з 18 років.
Пиво і вино - з 16 років. У компанії з батьками - вже з 14.
Але алкоголь і сигарети - це вже не круто.
За останні 35 років частка підлітків з 12 до 17 років,
які регулярно вживають алкоголь, знизилася з 30% до 10%.
А після 25 років частка курців знизилася з 27% до 7%.
Чим молодше покоління, тим воно мультикультурніше.
У кожного третього жителя Німеччини у віці
до 20 років хоча б один з батьків - іноземець.
Ось такі справи у підлітків Німеччини.
А що у вас? Напишіть нам у коментарях!